it it very kind of goes down to honestly  lord of the rings lord of the rings for  me  um  i grew up with tolkien  um middle earth so  and watching you guys on on on the  screen so it's just it's a huge honor to  be here with you guys oh that's fun um  and so to answer your question about the  berserker we kind of went with a like  kind of like a viking  you know kind of style on there yeah  that bottle though i think billy when  you messaged me earlier today you were  asking about milwaukee versus portland  locations yeah  so  it's a good indicator to see how old  that meat is because i can't remember  which ones i sent you um if the  blackberry says milwaukee on it no  that's what it means this one's bottled  in portland oregon portland okay so any  of the ones that might say  um milwaukee on there those ones have  been aging for at least two years  [Music]  night you're now bright i'm your boy's  the baby you're my prayer